miles de tropas polacas vigilan a lo
largo de la frontera con belarús donde
una valla de alambre de púas impide que
los migrantes crucen mientras los
migrantes esperan en los campamentos un
vídeo difundido por el ministerio de
defensa polaco muestra como
supuestamente las tropas de belarús
avanzan hacia un asentamiento de
emigrantes en la zona en medio de los
temores por un enfrentamiento mayor el
martes el primer ministro polaco se
reunió con las tropas en la frontera
calificando la situación como un ataque
que amenaza a la seguridad de la unión
europea y empezaría hace dos o tres
meses que nos enfrentaríamos acciones
que utilizan a personas como escudos
vivos el régimen de lukashenko utiliza a
civiles como armas de guerra híbrida
lo que podemos ver hoy son novedosos
métodos y ustedes son el bastión clave
contra ellos
el gobierno polaco ha acusado al
presidente bielorruso alexandr
lukashenko de utilizar a los migrantes
como arma animal es ir a la frontera
polaca con el objetivo de presionar a la
unión europea para que levante las
sanciones en su contra por supuestos
abusos de los derechos humanos algo que
belarús niega mientras tanto los
refugiados están atrapados en el medio
la mayoría tratando de escapar de la
guerra y la pobreza el medio oriente y
áfrica y entrar en la unión europea en
los campos las temperaturas han caído
por debajo de los cero grados y con poca
comida y suministros médicos al menos
diez personas ella han muerto